it's an ambitious goal to reduce U.S
greenhouse gas emissions by half by 2030
a promise made last year by President
Joe Biden this is a moral imperative
an economic imperative a moment of peril
but also a moment of extraordinary
possibilities
time is short but I believe we can do
this keeping that promise is now more
difficult a U.S Supreme Court ruling on
Thursday limited Biden's Environmental
Protection agency's ability to regulate
carbon pollution emitted by power plants
a major contributor of greenhouse gas
this ruling takes away one tool EPA has
to address the rising temperatures that
are caused by greenhouse gas emissions
the basis on which the court made the
decision is so broad that you could
apply the same logic to any number of
other regulations that the EPA or other
agencies
might Implement to try to address
climate change and activists fear the
conservative leaning Supreme Court is
now poised to block even more climate
initiatives
the Biden Administration is pursuing
options including new rules to limit
methane in natural gas but the epa's
power is limited that's because the
Supreme Court ruled it's the job of
Congress to regulate for many years
we've argued that the EPA only has the
attorney general who led the legal
challenge before the court believes
previously the EPA had overstepped its
Authority regardless of where you are on
the issue of climate change it's
important to play by the rules don't try
to use the agency process to
short-circuit congress's role under the
Constitution
but with just a narrow majority in the
Senate and with Congressional elections
in November there is no guarantee that
Biden's Democratic party will have the
seats much less the votes to push
forward his climate agenda for the
remainder of his term making future
efforts to fight climate change much
less certain
Kimberly helken Al Jazeera Washington